youth in London are being murdered by
their gang rivals at An unprecedented
rate almost half of murder victims and
suspects in the Capital are young black
men grossly disproportionate to london's
population Which is 13 Black many of
these Young men are children of trauma
born into inner City  poverty and Broken
Homes with absent fathers and scant
opportunity They are also pawns
sacrificed to our country's archaic
prohibition on drugs which artificially
inflates prices through criminalization
creating a lucrative market feeding
Dreams of a future escaping poverty
feeling just within reach until You're
murdered Uh leave  the embarrassing
campaigns to ban drill wap and the
opportunistic Race baiting of some for
electioneering purposes Let's Get real
The political Ping Pong being played by
london's mayor and the home Office over
Who's to blame is grating bad parenting
cuts to local police to mentoring
schemes youth services  and
extracurricular programs after school
and overdue drugs reform all contribute
be no If these were priv educated middle
Kids london's murder rate would have
been added a long time
[music]
Ag so i Share your concerns and i also
Share your frustrations in terms of this
has become a political pingpong youve
got sq saying It's not my fault It's the
police cours and that really frustrates
me but What also really really
frustrates
is the fact that no one seems to focus
on the word choice when you choose to
enter a gang and already  two of my
fellow panelist have
inhaled when you choose to enter a gang
and Don't Be mistaken It is a choice and
is a choice That is not going to end
well and all too often we talk about
Broken Homes abuse poverty lack of work
experience  I am a product Of A home That
is a broken That is an abusive home my
sister and i ha to admit this It Hurts
me my sister Used heroin She worked as a
prostitute and i made a choice I was on
An estate My Boyfriend was in  and out of
prison My Friends were with all respect
no herp and i made a choice I didn't
have someone Taking me by the hand and
leading me over there I didn't have
someone offering me money or Anything I
made the choice and the  choice that I
made was the right one and we'll talk
about gu did a great documentary Let's
look at one of these um guys I think he
calls himself K One Let's listen to what
He said I can see a gu over there
Because I don  't like him I go stab him
we w even actually put It as a gang is a
family It's not a gang It's a family We
all groups of Boys all grew up on the
same estate We mostly all went school
Together if if one of his  gang members
did to one of my gang members all of his
side of his gang I'll be after All Of
You l and all of my gang will be after
you l buse you disrespected one of my
family members So what I'll say is  this
two things firstly they look ridiculous
I I cannot s these people You're getting
I Know You Want To Move on but I want to
say these guys they expect respect
they're sitting there saying if you
disrespect me then I'm going to I  'm
going to defend gangs and affiliate to
gangs what I going to say is that the
choice that you refer to Some people
make it at 13 years old some make it at
14 years old I think we need to zoom out
a bit understand that children  are being
radical cri through gangs
and because Criminal the to Criminal
radicalization involves grooming similar
to extremist radicalization involves
older men minger men and all i want to
say or
nots and all SS things now all I'm
Saying is to zoom out a minute It's
important  for the rest of us that we
actually look at solutions because 13y
olds making wrong choices doesn't
actually solve the problem for us Can I
just say C First of all this issue
completely breaks My Heart I think the
amount of untapped potential That is
being  Lost because of What's Happening
to these Young men and I just want to
pick up on a couple of things that you
said Michelle so you've described your
background and and Uh the horrific Uh
ordeals that you you experienced as a
child but what I would  say to you are the
majority of people who come from a
similar background to Yours end up the
way your sister ended Up You are the
exception is no no no no no so There is
something about you that means that you
are not a product Of Your  environment So
what we know is we know the wonderful
thing within equ quality in societies We
Know What works so we know that if you
have a child that comes from An upper
middle class background that goes to a
good school that then is able to go to  a
good university and that has a Network
the chances are how going to end That
is going to end as a member of society
with many opportunities We Know pi a
child like the ones That is describing
and We look at their life options we
know how they  're going to end up so my
Point is I'm not interested in
exceptions horrified
what I to the Point you just made about
opportunities being there for them The
lady Who did this This Excellent report
kakim She said that she started out on
this to  make to make this film believing
that these Boys didn't have job
opportunity She says She has now
completely changed her mind She said
because what attracted them to the
gangs is not not having opportunity easy
money easy the want nice cars nice
whatever and That's  what they think is
available for them
other op trust let
me this rep got to me and and this is
this was a Line from one of the boys
this really broke My Heart he says I
don't know what this war is about
anymore All I  know is that If I step out
of my area that people people want to
kill me if I go into there He said this
War isn't going to end It's too Deep now
and you know I believe that I I don't I
don't  know what we can do sq kh talks
about you centers It's nonsense
actually we need to hear from He's come
in for huge amount of FL and grief
because of this Rise in Crime all over l
Let's hear from him CR been 2014 I
became the in 2016  cri been up across
the country not just London and we got
to do some of things firstly make
sure Young people know If you work hard
There is a help in hand And you can
fulfill your potential give the help in
hand but also explain to Young  people
There's a consequence if you get rich
Quick
intereses slightly backs car says Which
is that They have options
and If one of those Kids came to work
here think about How they would be
treated Because we didn't We haven created
a society that integrates Young men
like  family What we heard really from
here the takeaway is that They Don't
have properly functioning family networks
What the gang has
replac Can I just say that Let's go
through some more stats here Just
because It truly is alarming and and I I
just want to  make the Point that the
whole Point of me raising this was to
say let's not Play political football
with it Let's try and look for solutions
and so look 80 people have been murdered
in the first half of 2018 in London and
That's just shocking There are An
estimated 3280 Gang members in London
and % of m victims and suspects in
London in the last 18 months are young
black men I add to that and say that a
disproportionate number of them a hugely
disproportionate are both victims and
suspects under the Age of 21 what  I know
Can I just say something what I know is
that even if it is the reason I listed
multiple reasons for what could be
contributing to this is i don't think
it's One Thing or the other If someone
wants to get rich Quick It's usually
because they're not rich um So you know
that is related to poverty that could be
that to I said absent fathers said drugs
You're also Missing out syic
racism I think your Point at the end of
your intro was so spot on in that  we
would not be accepting this
from because for a long time because
people accus the Politics of being racist
foring these Young Black Kids know Do
what
I'm
finish sent and say that you know To Be
hest For Me whether It's About choices
whether It's About  laziness whether It's
at the end of the day society is
suffering and If WE remain solution
orientated If WE remain solution
orientated then It doesn't matter What
choice
choices so There's a direct correlation
between cuts to police forces and Rising
Crime The Police themselves are saying
that cuts to local services and
ringe got I
You're the ex as like got some
miracle What Point do you think that
these people become responsible for the
choices that they're
making
add s was responsible by way for the
choic
question when do these  people become
responsible for picking up Guns walking
around Shooting anding When is it their
responsibility are most of the time you
are a product Of Your environment
whatever is normal around you unless you
are the exception is what you usually
do I'm not saying It's not  the
responsibility I'm just saying that we
are not doing anything to actually
tackle the causes in terms of What is
considered normal in the areas that
those Boys are Growing Up inse those
same Boys not doing the same in other
parts helps
us I take responsibility  for this Panel